well there are fears that Lebanon could
be dragged further into the conflict the
UN peacekeeping force in Lebanon says
its headquarters in the south of the
country was hit by rocket fire there are
no reports of casualties now earlier at
least one Israeli was killed and three
wounded after Hezbollah said it targeted
a military post near the border in a
missile attack in response the Israeli
Army shelled lebanon's border and set up
a 4 kmet long buffer zone Ali hasham
reports from Southern Lebanon
during this day at least five attacks on
Military posts Israeli military posts
from hisbah and during one of the
exchanges we witnessed the launch of at
least 10 Rockets from the Lebanese
borders towards the Israeli borders and
there some of them were intercepted or
most of them was were intercepted by the
Israeli anti anti-missile system now
this is this is becoming a different
situation and the pattern of daily
attacks is kind of being enhanced
by's attacks today hasbullah says that
these attacks were in retaliation to the
killing of a journalist and some and
couple of citizens in the uh Eastern
east Southeast borders of Lebanon but if
we just go through the Israeli
retaliation today from the southwest
borders to the southeast borders that's
at 120 kilometers uh uh border uh every
and each uh uh sector of this border was
being bombarded today in R retaliation
tob's attacks and this raises the
concerns here that Lebanon is sliding
gradually into the bigger
conflict samada is the director of the
Levant Institute for strategic Affairs
he joins us from Beirut I thank you very
much for being on the program first of
all I want to ask you about the UN
peacekeeping force uh there in Lebanon
it's head qus was hit only a few hours
ago I know that this is a new and
unfolding situation but what more do you
know about it from where you are and how
big of a worry is
this nothing much in terms of uh
insights uh where these rockets that hit
the un uh uh uh uh the UN presence were
launch from uh uh however this is a very
symbolic uh uh uh attempt to be because
the UN presence there it's uh symbolizes
the Rules of Engagement that were uh
prevailing for at least the last decade
or decade and a half and the fact that
it was uh hit today uh it is like a
message that these rules of engagement
are about to change up to now the
exchange of uh uh fires between Israel
and hisbah on the Northern front of uh
Israel were uh under what uh we can call
the the the prevailing rules of uh
engagement uh Israel launching rocket
rockets and then Hezbollah replying on
she Farms which is a disputed area so in
a way it was business as usual is if we
can put it this way and the whole thing
was monitored by the UN forces today
targeting the UN forces and up to now we
didn't we don't know where these Rockets
are coming from and knowing where these
Rockets come from will uh uh give us
some uh insights in Reading who has
interest in uh uh uh escalating this war
and turning it into a regional uh uh uh
confrontation yeah our correspondent uh
who is in the area described it as a as
a tit fortat between hisbah and uh
Israeli forces I mean how uh does does
hisbah even want to be drawn into
this I don't think that heah as for now
want this War I don't think that he is
about to sustain uh the result and the
consequences of a war similar to that of
2006 uh because the conditions today are
totally different Lebanon is in a total
economic collapse 80% of its population
are living under uh uh the line of
poverty plus the Lebanese has still in
have still in mind the uh Beirut
explosion uh
Port uh uh cost on them practically half
of the City was destroyed and this was
because of Hezbollah involvement in the
war in in the region uh so however
however I would say if uh uh Iran Iran
would sense that it is about to lose uh
amas which is a key strategic asset for
uh Iran it's a very important pressure
card inside Israel so it's like uh Iran
hasing Cloud inside Israeli border
if it feels that it is
about the balance of power would change
at the detriment ofah or it is about to
lose the Strategic asset they Iran may
push hisbah to widen to escalate trying
to uh uh divert Israeli uh uh effort
military effort from Gaza to other
fronts okay thank you so much for that
we uh we really do appreciate your time
coming on ALG there that is
semida